ودونالد ترامب بينهما اختلافات جذريه في
الاراء والايديولوجيات فالاول الديمقراطي
والاخر جمهوري لكن خطا الاحتفاظ بالوثائق
السريه جمعهما البيت الابيض بعد انتظار
طويل للتوضيح اقر اخيرا بالعثور على وفائق
سريه تعود الى الفتره التي كان يتولى فيها
الرئيس جو بايدن منصب نائب الرئيس في حديد
باراك اوباما اين تحدث بين 2009 و 2007
2017 البيت الابيض قال انه عثر على عدد
صغير من الوثائق السريه في منزل بيض الخاص
في االمتون في ولايه زلاوور كما عثر على
وثائق اخرى مصنفه سريه في مركز بحوث في
واشنطن حيث كان يملك بايضا
لكنها بايظ نفع في وقت سابق علمه بمحتوى
وثائق مشيرا الى انه حلم اكتشف محامه ان
بعض هذه الوفاء كان سريا اتصلوا الفئه
المحفوظات لتسليم نهائيا واعرب عن
استعداده التام للتعاون مع الجهات المعنيه
والمعلومات السريه على محمل الجده عندما
كان المحامون يفرغون مكتبي في جامعه
بنسلفانيا انشا لمكتب امنا في الكابيتول
عندما عملت لمده اربع سنوات وكنت نائبا
لرئيس ووجدوا بعض المستندات في صندوق هنا
كما تعلم في خزانه مغلقه او على الاقل
مقفله وبمجرد ان فعلوا ذلك ادركوا ان هناك
العديد من المستندات السريه في ذلك
الصندوق وفعلوا ما كان ينبغي عليهم فعله
واقام على الفور بالاتصال بهيئه المحفوظات
لتسليمها
عاصفه انتقادات اثيرت بعد العثور على
التلك الوفاق السريه في عهده بايدي لكنها
لم تكن من الجمهوريين وحدهم بحسب صحيفه
وسن جورنال لكن من انصار بايضن
الديمقراطيه ايضا حيث دعوا الى اجراء
تحقيقات لمعرفه كيف تم الاحتفاظ بهذه
الوثائق السريه في مركز ابحاث بايدن الذي
يرتاده طلاب ويمكن ان يدخله اي شخص اخر
وبالفعل اعلنت وزاره العدل تعيين مدعي عام
مستقل لتحقيق في هذه القضيه وبحسب وصف
الجنه فان اكتشاف الوفاق سيزيد الضغط
السياسي على بايد خاصه بعد تحقيقات لوزاره
العدل في قضيه مشابهه نتحدث عن الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وبعد حصول الجمهوريين
على اغلبيه المقاعد في مجلس النواب
الامريكي وتولي كيف المقار في رئاسه
المجلس ستصبح ملاحقه الجمهوريين حتمياتا
اكد على بعدها تاكيد الباقيت الابيض بوجود
الوثائق اكد ضروره التحقيق مع بيضين
بشيانها
[موسيقى]
الوثائق السريه التي عثر عليها في منزل
ومكتب الرئيس هو شخص بقي في الحكومه لاكثر
من 40 عاما هذا الشخص كان حريصا جدا على
النظر بامر وثائق الرئيس ترامب والان نجد
انه عندما كان نائبا للرئيس احتفظ بالعديد
من الوثائق السريه باماكن مختلفه
والحياه
سيسيطر على الاخبار بالايام القادمه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يطهر
الى فلوريدا حيث مار لاجو مقر اقامه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب عثر في اغسطس
الماضي على وثائق سريه الى درجه ان موظفي
مكافحه التجسس تابعين لمكتب التحقيقات
فيدرالي ومحامي وزاره العدل الى تصاريح
اضافيه قبل ان يسمح لهم بالاطلاع على
وثائق محدده وعثر في الصناديق ال 15 التي
سلمها ترامب على مئه
واربعه او اربع منه وثيقه تحمل عباره سريه
او سريه للغايه رغم مغادره ترامب في البيت
الابيض في 20 21 صحيفه واشنطن بوست كشفت
حين ذلك عن ان احدى الوثائق السريه اذا
انكشفت حين ذلك عن ان احدى هذه الوثائق
التي صدرها الاف بي اي تتضمن للقدرات
النوويه والدفاعات العسكريه لقوه اجنبيه
وقالت الصحيفه ان بعض الوثائق التي عثر
عليها في مقر اقامه ترامب في مراغو كانت
سريه جدا الى درجه ان الرئيس ومسؤولي
الحكومه او من هم في مستوى قريب لذلك يسمح
لهم بتفويض مسؤولين حكوميين اخرين
السريه وضعت الاداره الامريكيه في موقف
حرج ومع التطورات التي تظهر تباعا يتوقع
ان تستمر القضيه في اثاره الضجه وقد يتبين
انها تعرقل تحقيقا حول وثائق ترامب ويرى
محللون ان هذه القضيه قد تدخل في اعتبارات
سياسيه حساسه قد تدخل ذلك في التحقيق
المرتبط بترامب الذي دعا فورا استغل ذلك
الى ان يخضع بيضا للتحقيق بنفسك وتسال متى
سيدهم الاف بي اي مقررات جو بايدن الكثيره
او حتى البيت الابيض وطرحت صحيفه في ما
قال راي سبب اثاره الضجه حول وثائق ترامب
قبل فتره قليله من الانتخابات النصفيه
للتشكيك في نزاهه الجمهوريين واساءه
استخدامهم للسلطه ودفعت واشنطن بوست بان
وثائق بان عثر عليها في الثاني من نوفمبر
قبل اسبوع من الانتخابات الا ان الكشف
عنها كان قبل ايام فقط والاكيد الان ان
ترامب سيسعى للاستفاده من الموقف بعد تورط
بايدي في ازمه ممثله اريد تسليما
اكتشاف الوثائق السريه في مكتب الرئيس
اعتمر في الاوساط السياسيه اجبر هديه قد
يحصل عليها الرئيس دونالد ترامب الذي دعى
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي الى مداهمه منزل
بايدن كما فعل في مقر اقامته في مرغو في
اغسطس الماضي زاعما في الوقت نفسه ان
السلطات لن تضطهد بعيدا بالطريقه التي
تعرضه نفسه لها الامر الذي يخدم ما يروج
له ترامب لدى جمهوره من المحافظين او ما
يعرف بالماجا بانه يتعرض لمعايره مزدوجه
في التعامل لكن السؤال يبقى اذا ما كانت
هذه السياسه التي يتبعها ترامب والتي نجح
فيها لفتره طويله اذا ما كان لها تاثير
على الحزب الجمهوري وعلى المحافظين داخل
الحزب واذا ما كانت كفيله باستعاده نفوذ
ترامب داخل الحزب الجمهوري النفوذ الذين
راينا افوله خلال الانتخابات المطالبه
لرئيس مجلس النواب في الكونغرس والارتفاع
بها كافه في الجوله الخامسه عشر
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب الى الالتفاف
حول ممثل كاليفورنيا لكن تم تحديه علنا من
قبل بعض مؤيديه الاكثر ولاا بما في ذلك
لورين بوبرد ومات غيتس
[موسيقى]